okay now i've got
another question and and uh
this you got to forgive my ignorance for
this one and maybe it's not even an
appropriate question to begin with
but as a guy i have to that i'm just
curious and fascinated about the idea of
with women's fighting if let's say your
big huge fight you know you're
headlining an event and it just so
happens to land during the week that you
have your period
how does that like influence the uh
the the the performance or the fight um
your weight cut is harder
and your titties are bigger if you check
out my fight against alexis davis
you will see an example of that
i had some big old titties punching her
in the face yeah it just makes the
weight cut harder
okay that's why i always wore black
shorts because i was always really
[ __ ] paranoid about that [ __ ]
that's that's that and mike tyson wore
black shorts i was like oh that's cool
but also
like what if it's the wrong day
[Laughter]
damn those white shorts are scary i
ain't going anywhere near that [ __ ]
that's that's hilarious yeah i was i was
i was asking
lux last time i was like i said if is it
like [ __ ] up if i ask this question
and uh she wasn't like you know
feeling strongly one way or the other
but then i said you know well i will
you know i can tell ronda
that from my experience particularly
with
lux if the fight landed
in like the days just leading up to
before the period started
that that would give lux like a huge
advantage
[Laughter]
should be ultra aggressive because
mostly just affects the weight cut
and you're like god damn it like i had
like a string of fights from like
statistically this would be [ __ ]
impossible like why am i like my weight
cuts always this hard like
yeah it's just kind of roll the dice man
it sucks sometimes women [ __ ]
just happens the wrong time did you just
have to deal with it
i had um i had a chick show up and she
was like i can't make weight because i'm
on my period and i'm like [ __ ] you
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] answer
you know that you had a vagina when you
signed up for this
like you can't act like you weren't
ineligible to fight a fourth of your
life
[ __ ] off make way don't be a [ __ ]
that's so that's so interesting to me
because um
i mean [ __ ] it it would imagine
i would imagine that you would hear that
excuse all the time
from like female fighters missing wait
like tatiana suarez missed weight by
like seven and a half pounds i think one
time
like she didn't even say yo i'm on the
rag
dude there's really no excuse to cut
weight
you're a professional you know when the
match is going to be
like you are paid to show up and make
way
on that day and if you are unable to do
that
then don't promise that you're gonna do
it you know
like um but you know i have like a
different perspective about it
i the only time i missed wait and judo i
moved up to the next division the very
next tournament and i never went back
down again because i'm like
well i guess i can't make the [ __ ]
way anymore you know and and that's it
it's uh you gotta show up and you gotta
do your job
we're we're professionals if you're not
a professional then like what the [ __ ]
are you doing there get ready this is
gonna be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready
[Music]
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad yeah
you're gonna hurt me gonna piss me off